so I looked at the topic of what's
happening in the brain when we deal with
money and there's a part of the brain
that activates it's called the nucleus
accumbens it's deep within this sort of
evolutionary the oldest part of the
brain and they compared people who make
money to those who are high on cocaine
and remarkably the brain scans were
almost identical because there was
activation in this part of the brain
called the nucleus accumbens they've
also looked at brain scans of people who
are high looking looking at women naked
women dead bodies and money it what got
the most activation it was money so
money obviously acts as a neuro
stimulant and it makes us act in very
sort of irrational ways and so the part
that the brain lights up again the
nucleus accumbens keeps on firing and
firing and firing and obviously money
excites us the nucleus accumbens is part
of the reward center of the brain and
it's part of the brain that activates
when you're excited when you're aroused
when you're feeling happiness or or even
joy and I was part of the there's many
parts of the brain to activate when
using money but this is where it's
concentrated where we process rewards
and brain scientists have been able to
scan your brain and they say okay you
can invest in a stock that's more risky
a conservative bond or someone gets that
no option at all I got like a my cash
right and so they find that if there's
activation in the nucleus accumbens
you're more likely to take the risk of
your option I mean you're more likely to
choose a stock well there's activation
in the insula which is the anxiety
center of the brain you're more likely
to be risk averse and you're taking on
investing in the bonds so what they find
is that obviously what happens in the
brain can predict what your financial
decision is decision making our
financial decision making is made at
what's called the subcortical region
below the New York toward neocortex what
we all know is the subconscious level
for example when you sit outside on a
sunny day you're more likely to tip more
for the waiter you feel like you're in a
better mood that the Sun affects you and
you tip more money whereas if you sit on
sit inside YouTube less money so
researchers went back
look to this and they said well one
thing that we have really good data on
our weather patterns over the last 80
years we also have really good data on
stock market prices over 26 countries
and it found that sure enough over 80
years that the markets are up
considerably
I'm analyzer 25 percent on sunny days
versus those cloudy days so it goes to
show you that our brains are constantly
being bombarded by all kinds of effects
the weather how I service investors for
a living and I never heard a
professional investors say hmm how does
the weather make me feel how should I
invest but it's clearly having an impact
on us so the takeaway here is we should
be mindful of how the brain had the
money has a physiological change on us
right so when I mentioned the word money
to you the thought of making money
increases your skin conductance e you're
getting excitement from it so I take
away shion's to be mindful that a lot of
our financial decisions making are being
made even when we don't think we're
making them money is having an
imperceptible effect on us one of the
things that research finds is that when
they flash the price of an object to you
the part of your brain that activates is
the prefrontal cortex meaning the part
of the brain that sort of makes us human
the part that evolved to give
self-awareness and reflection so in a
point when we see the price that part of
the brain activates and when the price
is too expensive the insula activates
which is again part of the fear sensor
and when you make a bad financial
decision you may feel in your gut and
there's actually a reason for that
because there's a part of there's a cell
called a spindle cell and it's there's
some spindle cells in your stomach and
that they're connected to your insula in
the brain so when you make an irrational
financial decision when you put money in
that stock and it falls precipitously
you feel it in your insula you feel like
in your gut that oh my gosh it's a
neurological mechanism and so
increasingly I think we're gonna be
seeing neuroscientists they'll be able
to forecast our financial
decision-making based on what's
happening in our brains and they look at
studies of identical twins and when they
separate identical twins they find that
they invest in a similar
manor right between stocks bonds and
cash and currency and of course genetics
isn't the only thing but genetics has a
strong influence not just on how we
spend but even our credit scores in one
study they found that there's this one
gene and those who have one variant of
the gene are more likely to be risk
averse have fewer credit lines and a
higher FICO scores have higher credit
scores and just the inverse of that if
you have that another cop another
variant of that gene so it shows that
genes can help influence our credit
score in a very statistically
significant way